Dozens of Ukrainian troops
are wrapping up their training in Spain.
On the left
for two tanks
Western allies agreed to send
to help Ukraine in its fight.
This is part of a coordinated effort
with Spain, Germany,
Norway, Poland, Portugal
and the Netherlands to supply Kiev
with around 80 leopard two vehicles.
Our next guest is a US Army veteran
who has been fighting alongside Ukrainian
since the beginning
and sharing his experience
with us from the ground.
We're happy to join Mira Popovich
or have him join us here.
He is back in the US for the first time
since the start of the war.
Mira, thank you.
We appreciate you joining us.
Good morning to you.
So we're happy to see that you're safe.
You're heading back to Ukraine tomorrow.
Your assessment of where you think
this war is one year out.
And I mean, you've been,
you know, fighting for a year.
Well, you know, since day one,
I think the whole world was giving
us, what, two, three days?
And here we are one year later and
we are fighting back. And
our armed forces
have liberated much of our territory.
I know it's still a long way to go, but,
you know, we are on the right track,
of course,
obviously, with the support from Europe
and the United States.
And the whole world
that cherishes the freedom
and the human rights.
Now, with all that help,
we are on the right
track to
end this war as soon as possible.
You said you're surprised
that it's still going on even this long.
We hit the one year mark.
We talked about what that meant.
What is it like being on the ground
there you get
when you've been told
who's been there, you're going
back is done.
What is it like there?
Well, you know what
I can say, it's horrible.
And it'll be the right statement.
But, you know,
we as humans,
we can get used to anything.
And probably one year later,
I get used to seeing horrible
and tremendous things
or being under fire.
You get used to this,
but it's not normal, obviously, now.
But it is I tell you this.
I want to.
It is amazing
to see how united Ukrainians are
and the whole world around us and to see
from any.
I've been to Kharkiv,
Hertzel Nicolai of Kiev,
all these cities
and everywhere you see people united
It's amazing.
Yeah.
Why did you come back
to the United States?
I have to find my Texas United States.
I mean, as a citizen,
I haven't flown North Texas in 21.
And I have to file for 22.
And my driver's license was expiring.
My U.S.
passport was expiring
because it's been a long time.
So I had to come here
and you know, do those little things.
And
and the other thing is, Andrew, leave
Newark from Boombox,
you know, the Pink Floyd guy
you had the guy who sang with Pink Floyd.
We are in the same team.
So he came here with a tour with his band
Boombox to raise money for Ukraine.
Humanitarian and military aid.
So I'm here
sort of helping him out as well.
One big thing we've been talking about
this morning
is also the politics here at home
and support for Ukraine,
because we've heard
Biden in the admin
talk about supporting Ukraine
as long as it takes.
But Ron DeSantis is someone
who is expected
to enter the Republican race.
He is polling the closest
to Trump of anyone else.
And he said last night
he doesn't think the US
should be involved
in what he called
a territorial dispute
between Ukraine and Russia.
Are you worried
about the future politics here
and how that affects support for Ukraine?
What's this guy's name?
Ron DeSantis.
He's from the Sanders
a Florida yeah, I heard his name as well.
I want to let him know
that this is not the territorial dispute.
Russia is has invaded
Ukraine to destroy, demolish, rape, kill.
And
it's it's not a territorial dispute.
So hopefully this guy doesn't win.
But
But what was the question again?
Just the concern about support,
what the support could look like
and the US
commitment and
broader commitment to Ukraine.
Of course,
you know, the United States
supports Ukraine very much.
And I am concerned
if the support will stop,
it'll be harder for us because
we already paid the highest price,
the ultimate price.
I mean, tens of thousand people died.
And I've seen the cities demolished.
For example, for instance, city of Kiev
where 10,000 people live
there is demolished.
100% there is no more, there's no more.
The city doesn't exist anymore.
So this is not a territorial dispute.
This is life or death.
So as someone said, if
Russia stops shooting,
there'll be no war.
If Ukraine stops shooting, there'll
be no Ukraine. So
that's exactly what is happening.
Before you go, can we
can you tell us what your shirt,
the shirt. Yes.
This is the Saint Javelin shirt
props to Saint Javelin
I think it's the Saint Mary
that's holding a javelin
and they call it, say,
the protector of Ukraine,
which obviously has been
critical for Ukraine. Yes.